sexy can i was like it was a blessing
though cause um i'll never forget um
when we did the final record what year
was that 2008 damn yep yep so when we
did when we were finalizing the record i
wrote my little verses or whatever um
i wrote my verses like in miami and i
went to the studio with my friend at the
time the girl who sang the hook on the
business cashier and i went with um and
and ray j we went to encore and ray j
was there just like after he did his
vivid deal or whatever so like he was on
a different level like he was
we've all been everyone's seen his dick
by this time bro he's in a different bag
so we go in there and like he's asking
cash or like yo um you mind if i play
these like these videos he pulls out
like dvds and it's like vivid porns and
[ __ ] or whatever and like i'm like bro
play that [ __ ] i don't care like you
know this is my different area
it's my homie like this my girl like
she's saying this ain't no no super
duper relationship just like my best
friend so um
tiara marie was there with him and i
think that was his girlfriend at the
time while we were doing it crazy enough
and um he did we finished the record and
um
we went to miami we shot the video and
upon shooting a video like the first
take of the video i'm smoking up a blunt
it's probably like a roach we about to
shoot the first shot i inhaled it once
and i throw it out the lamborghini the
police that were securing us on the set
came and picked up the roach and took me
to jail before the first shot of the
whole video on sexuality yeah we was in
miami because you threw a blunt out yeah
they took me to jail on a set of sexy
cannot i went to jail and the crazy
thing is shaquille and ray j was
partners and shaquille o'neal ended up
bailing me out of jail and so i could
come back to the video i didn't get out
of jail until probably wait shaq bailed
you out yeah i didn't get out of jail
until probably like
9 00 p.m
so it's from like uh 9 00 am like i said
that's all night in jail yeah oh man